everybody's gamescom 2014 Sean McInnes
and Andy Bauman we have just stepped out
of the Forza horizon 2 appointment over
an xbox and Andy is one of those one of
those demos that showed off about seven
thousand different features and as much
of a rapid-fire fashion as you could
possibly imagine so confirmed for
summarizing to to feature seven thousand
different features you can put that one
in the bank the only thing I took away
from it is the guy driving really hid
cafes and a mediterranea town of nice or
whatever we were showing off you know
the city of nice in the South of France
yeah and just the kind of free roaming
you can do and one immediate take away
is that you can be a real dick to
tourists at cafes and knees you just
drift that Lambo right into the cafe
corners around every corner apparently I
can't tell me was getting bonus points
or not translated into game marketing
terms improved destruction physics yeah
so yeah you can do that to cafes other
stuff I mean they're kind of focusing on
the seamlessness of the online world so
one kind of neat little feature is that
if you're driving around and you see
this little icon that says P that means
that there's a car meet going on in the
nearby car park so there's kind of like
scenic overlooks that you
parkin it's a bunch of different players
it's essentially like they're all
hanging out tailgating looking at each
other's cars just chillin havin a good
time you can you can inspect everybody's
builds make bars or customization and
their liveries which is a word I'm don't
use very often but the paint job I think
huh yeah it is a paint job yeah and you
can copy them or buy them from them you
see yeah you can you can get those
deliveries immediately and the other
drivers will be compensated yeah you
know the reinforced theft economy and
forza horizon 20 was cool one of the
other neat things is those playground
game multiplayer events that we're in
Forza horizon one stuffed like infected
and the king of the hill mode we have a
smash into one player and the person who
yeah most recently done to Smashing for
long enough ways you know how it goes
previously and Verizon line you would
play those and like up like a golf
course around the field or something but
they actually have discrete multiplayer
arenas for those that have like jumps
and hiding spots and that kind of stuff
yeah they showed off this old monastery
and the one we played or they showed us
the monastery yeah I thought it was like
old Roman ruins yeah it was something
like that an old Roman monastery so they
had like archways that your cars kids
like drift through and they had that the
jumps that everybody was going off
trying to chase down the guy and if you
run into him you becoming the guy with
the crown and then everybody chases you
around it looked pretty fun actually you
can you know run your Ford Raptor around
with us yeah oh you're they have new
cars of the 200 cars over hundred
pajaros will launch including the dogs
eat runner the 63 VW camper oh yeah 45
willys jeep and others and they are
really proud to say that some of the
cars you'll only find
I don't think they're out in real life
yet no they're not so there's like a
fever dream on the part of Microsoft and
playground and one last little bone that
we're going to throw to the fans with
simulation racing games the tuning
system reports a motorsport that was
never around in horizon one will be
included in horizon 2 so gear ratios are
gonna get slightly tweaked and horizon 2
and how will the how will those you know
work in the rain I don't know at you I
don't know only there's only one way to
find out stay tuned to gamespot colors
for horizon to coverage weather system